all right six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty we're going to go to
someone who's been holding on for a long
time that our caller from seven one six
has been on hold for a while so I
predict that their question must be
really really good seven one sixth
caller what's your name where are you
calling from and what can I answer for
you today my name is Brendan I'm calling
from New York right and I was wondering
who do you think has caused more
significant damage during the first days
in office their first 100 days Bush or
Trump ah that's that's really tough to
say because so if we think legislatively
Bush got way more done during his first
hundred days then did Donald Trump
significant legislation that george w
bush got done during his first hundred
days and if he hadn't passed his tax
plan in the first hundred days it had at
least been fully formed already and so i
think that an actual legislative
standpoint it was george w bush who
accomplished more during his first
hundred days mostly things that were a
disaster on the other hand donald trump
during his first hundred days has been a
far bigger embarrassment than was george
w bush and we're going to do a story
soon about just the way that Donald
Trump is being perceived around the
world and how the United States is quite
literally becoming the laughingstock of
the developed and developing world so
while a lot of Donald Trump's executive
orders for example have been more
symbolic than anything else I think that
it's a it's a sort of practicality
versus optics question do you have a
strong feeling on this Pat I mean it's a
really a well framed question who did
more damage I mean it's just hard to
pinpoint what he actually did in his
first 100 days because George Bush's
presidency was so long ago yeah and you
know you can kind of get it confused
with the rest of his presidency whereas
Trump we're still early on into it I
think here's how I would answer it
Brendan I would say that in his first
hundred days George W Bush did more
irreversible damage via legislation but
that Donald Trump did more
or a sort of PR and reputational damage
and again we're out of the first hundred
days now I mean I what's your sense of
it Brendon am i at all on point here
yeah yeah I see where you're coming from
but I definitely think because Trump
East didn't you sign a bill they got
like a seven percent approval rating or
something like that well I mean I don't
know about seven percent approval but
certainly the latest version of the
American Health Care Act has seventeen
percent approval so it looks like George
Bush proposed the No Child Left Behind
education reform and he also started
working on that one plus trillion dollar
tax cut yeah that used Bill Clinton
stimulus money to fund yeah so that
certainly was a disaster that's kind of
hard to compete with he worked on it
during the first hundred days but was it
passed and again we'd have to go back to
the exact timeline
all right Brendan thanks so much very
very good question well put very much
appreciated it was worth holding on for
that long